l'afrique est prise en otage il s'agit
de la guerre de la russie contre nous il
ne s'agit pas d'une crise c'est une
guerre brutale
avez vous entendu tout cela de la part
de vos partenaires russes avec qui vous
êtes restés en contact je suis persuadé
qu'ils vous disent tout le contraire
mais il faut dire qu'ils ont besoin de
cette crise qui maintiennent sciemment
délibérément ils se servent de vous ces
sanctions ne sont là que pour empêcher
la russie de nous réduire en esclaves
bonjour gauthier rybinski n'ont jamais
suivi je prends l'intégralité du
discours de volodymyr zelensky et le
président évoque également une guerre
coloniale ça fait forcément écho en
afrique ça fait forcément écho parce que
récemment quand le président sénégalais
qui est le président en exercice de
l'union africaine s'est rendu en russie
pour voir vladimir poutine celui ci
n'avait pas manqué de lui rappeler
combien l'union soviétique s'était
engagé à l'époque dans les années 1960
1950 1960 pour l'indépendance des pays
africains et pour justement les ôter à
la à la tutelle coloniale et aujourd'hui
on voit que cet argument a eu encore
courait encore peser dans le jugement
des chefs d'état africains puisque on se
rend compte que finalement les anciennes
puissances coloniales l'ex tutelle celle
qui était qui dominait ses états
africains que cette afrique là prenons
la france sont parties prenantes à plus
ou moins grande échelle dans ce conflit
ukraine russe et à partir de là il ya
une tentation qui est grande en afrique
de s'opposer finalement via cette guerre
en ukraine à l'ancienne puissance
coloniale autrement dit les ennemis de
mes ennemis sont mes amis c'est un
comment dire acheter tu te fais une
séquelle c'est un résidu du coup du
complexe coloniale qui n'est pas encore
tout à fait digéré et qui donc trouve
son expression dans cette guerre ukraine
russie là où c'est intéressant c'est que
dans la démarche de zelensky il s'agit
donc de prouver aux chefs d'état
africains
qu'il y a dans cette guerre quelque
chose qui dépasse de très loin
l'histoire immédiate mais qui met en
cause le statut même de l'humanité et
comment nous considérons les êtres
humains c'est ce que veut dire et lens
qui à travers la phrase selon laquelle
lorsqu'il précise que les russes mènent
une guerre impérialiste et que donc il
s'agit finalement de sauver oui de
sauver l'être humain de sauver ce qu'il
en reste c'est à dire de ne pas
considérer que comme vladimir poutine
considère que ces conscrits sont de la
chair à canon de la piétaille de la
valetaille et bien il ne faut pas que le
reste de l'humanité en soi
comment dirais-je en soient victimes et
en pâtissent ça s'est compliqué à faire
comprendre parce que le fond de la faire
c'est aussi que l'afrique souffre
énormément de cette guerre dont est ce
que vous les africains vont voir
concrètement peut-être un jour le les
effets de cette guerre pour eux ils
commencent déjà à l'aller ressentir
c'est un problème bien sûr
d'approvisionnement céréales puisqu'on
sait que la russie et l'ukraine sont
grandes pourvoyeuses en céréales c'est
aussi un problème d'engrais puisque
l'ukraine exporte beaucoup de beaucoup
d'anglais alors zelensky a signalé qu'il
y avait des négociations en cours
extrêmement difficile dit il pour que
les fournitures les livraisons
ukrainienne en céréales et en anglais
puisse partir puisque vous savez que par
la mer noire et bien le lit issue est
bouché si j'ose dire dans la mesure où
les la flotte russe boucle et exerce un
blocus donc là c'est compliqué mais si
on revient en arrière il y a quand même
bien fait qui n'est pas discutable c'est
la capacité théorique de l'afrique à
produire des céréales le blé certes ce
n'est pas une céréale africaine mais il
y a des pays par exemple comme
l'ethiopie ou le kenya qui pratiquent
très bien la culture du blé de sorte que
l'on pourrait envisager à terme une
autosuffisance alimentaire de l'afrique
idem pour les anglais des engrais pardon
il faut un terrain propice un terreau
propice l'afrique là ça n'a pas été fait
d'une manière ou d'une autre ou idem
pour les structures les infrastructures
qui permettent à ces marchandises de
circuler elles ne sont pas présentes
donc en théorie l'afrique peut
mais elle ne peut pas pour l'instant
subvenir à ses besoins parce qu'elle est
en retard et du coup elle se trouve
contrainte d'aller voir poutine en
quelque sorte comme on va à canossa pour
lui dire de grâce arrêtez ça parce que
nous nous allons en souffrir nous
souffrons déjà on dirait les européens
avec l'énergie est exactement il n'y a
pas de différence à ce niveau là il ya
une forme de soumission et donc le
habilement ce que zelensky a essayé de
faire avec les chefs d'état africains
c'est de leur dire vous avez à juste
titre la prétention d'avoir un rôle
prépondérant et clé sur la scène
internationale si vous êtes dépendant de
vladimir poutine pour x raisons vous ne
pouvez pas avoir ce rôle prépondérant
donc considérer que ça n'est pas en vous
soumettant à vladimir poutine même s'il
y a des raisons que vous allez gagner il
faut que vous soyez partie prenante dans
cette guerre avec le sentiment que vous
êtes derrière la justesse et la justice
et donc évidemment ça veut dire aussi
c'est l'accusé ans qui a joué ça veut
dire que il va tout faire lui pour que
les exportations de céréales puissent
être fournis comme d'habitude à
l'afrique ça c'est une autre paire de
manches voilà pour ce message décrypter
de volodine zelensky par gauthier
rybinski